so your new campaign for your project
love touch heat is on IndieGoGo whereas
previously you want with Kickstarter and
unfortunately you weren't successful
with it but it's sold wonderful project
that I do hope you make what was the
reason for going with IndieGoGo okay so
very specifically I get people helping
on the producer wanted to do it on
IndieGoGo and honest it's it's a small
indie film and i think the other
kickstart people are really awesome but
it's kick starts kind of morphing into i
know they probably don't they wish it
weren't this way i mean i think they're
like really awesome and they really
we're trying to do something good and
they have done they've really changed
our lives but it's become much more of a
pre-sale kind of website you know it's
it's kind of the indie spirit it's God I
did a first I did any documentary when
Kickstarter just like came into
existence like three months into
existence and it was very like all I
else is cool you know oh we're
supporting something and now it's
IndieGoGo seems i should say seems much
more of a like you're donating and in
the film could or couldn't work as we're
kick-started the money has gotten so big
that has attracted a lot of industrial
design and video games and they're
really just kind of pre-sales like hey
yeah give us money will ship out the
game to you so for us the movie is kind
of little hey it's a little teeny movie
it just seems like yeah a little teen
movie go indiegogo much more mainstream
things like our docs kind of go for
kickstarter well it seems like you were
having way more success now with love
touch hate than you did with instruction
and faith so what do you think's changed
most specifically for us i know our
documentaries on adultery and that I you
know I've had friends tell me oh I
really want to see the movie but I don't
want to be associated with funding that
per se
you know which sons but it's on adult
they don't really know if it's pro
adultery which is probably our fault if
not kind of saying it's not pro tall
tree or against adultery it's just
talking about it so yeah get that and
then like our little indie you know the
indie film is it's much more of a
likeable kind of thing where I said yeah
I like to support this it looks kind of
neat the guy transfers love seems like
an interesting concept it's that's
basically the gist of it
you